This will not be a normal Wendover Productions
Video.
That’s because I’m getting a Patreon,
but first I need to show you why.
So… at 5 am on a recent Saturday morning
I woke up, left my apartment, walked downtown,
took a bus, took a plane, took a bus, took
a train, then arrived here—an open field.
It may seem strange that I traveled over 200
miles to an open field, but this was no ordinary
open field.
This was Argleton—a place that was once
a story in every major newspaper worldwide.
Now, this place may sound familiar to some
of you—I talked about it in TWL episode
three.
Argleton exists, but only according to some
maps—it’s a paper town.
Back in ye olde days, mapping companies devoted
an enormous amount of resources to just figuring
out what existed where.
They had to survey every physical place, map
every road, plot every mountain just so they
knew what to put on maps.
Some figured out, though, that they didn’t
have to go out and survey places.
They could just copy the information from
other maps.
They were, after all, mapping the same world
so, in theory, there would be no way to tell
if they were plagiarizing.
That’s why paper towns were created.
These towns never existed in real life.
They were just randomly and arbitrarily placed.
If competing maps suddenly started listing
paper towns, such as Argleton, their source
would know and could prove that they were
plagiarizing since there’s certainly no
way that they would get the false information
from surveying.
Modern maps are constantly updated and adjusted
using new technologies like satellite and
gps, but, a good amount of the information
on our 21st century maps comes from centuries
old maps.
Modern day companies such as TomTom and TeleAtlas
acquired much of their information from sightly
older companies who acquired their information
from even older companies and so on and so
forth.
So remnants of those 19th and 20th century
maps sometimes will show up today.
Argleton is one of those remnants.
Some time down the line some company placed
Argleton on the map as a copyright trap, and
decade after decade nobody noticed even when
it got onto digital maps.
Nobody’s actually sure when it got there.
Tele Atlas, who sourced mapping information
for Google in the region, tried to figure
out where Argleton originated from but came
out inconclusive.
After it was pointed out that, in truth, Argleton
really is just this field, Google removed
the town from it’s listings.
In there area, there’s no trace of the paper
town that once received worldwide media attention.
There are no signs, no souvenirs, nothing,
even for perhaps the most famous fake town
in history.
So now’s when I talk about money.
If there’s no way I’ll ever convince you
to contribute to my Patreon, you can go, but
I do encourage you to hear me out.
I was able to do such a ridiculous thing as
traveling 200 miles to an empty field because
of your guys’ support of the channel.
I think that this video is much better than
the original video I made about Argleton partially
because I was able to go to Argleton in person,
and I want to do things like that more.
I’ve grown enormously, and through adsense,
liscensing, and freelance this channel is
now basically my job.
I make enough through those sources to support
myself, but I want this channel to improve.
That’s why I’ve started this Patreon.
Every dollar you give to my Patreon will be
spent directly on the channel.
I’m serious about that.
I will not take a dime of what you contribute.
I’m even going to release a monthly report
showing you where your money went.
The cool thing about this arrangement is that
the 2, or 5, or 10 dollars you contribute
will come right back to you in the form of
a better video.
You will be directly affecting the quality
and quantity of Wendover Productions videos.
They’re a couple things I want to spend
this money on.
As with this Argleton video, I think there’s
value in getting real footage of real places,
along with doing research and interviews on
location.
Some of the money will likely go to travel
expenses to get to these places.
Additionally, I’d love to hire animators
and sound designers and others to improve
the quality and quantity of my videos.
I’m not going to change format, I promise
you.
I will always have the same simple, clear
animations in my videos, they’ll just be
cleaner and smoother.
So a big part of the money will go to this
mad push for better production quality.
I’ve tried to create some really rewarding
rewards.
At only $2 per video, you’ll have early
access to my videos, access to the behind-the-scenes
Patreon feed, and you can wipe your conscience
clean for using adblock.
At $5 you’ll get a handwritten letter and
stickers sent to wherever you live.
$15 gets you into a super secret group-chat
with me and other high-level supporters and
your name will be eternalized in the description
of all videos you support.
$20 per video will get you an awesome looking
Wendover Productions t-shirt.
There are some higher tiers too but I won’t
go over them here because I doubt many people
will actually use them.
Also, just to be clear, at whatever tier you
support, you also get the rewards of the lower
levels.
So, if you have the means to, I would love
your support on Patreon.
I don’t need this money to keep doing this
channel, I only want it to improve the channel.
So thank you, and goodnight.